Haschisch, in rauen Mengen.
Direkt geliefert bis vor die Haustür.
Drogentaxis – werden gern auch im Gangsterrap besungen.
Bonez MC: Die Taschen voll mit Geld wegen Kokain,
das Taxi wird bestellt, sie haben Bock zu
ziehen.
Drogenkuriere, bestellt per Messenger-Chat
direkt vor die Haustür.
Haftbefehl: Cocaine Cowboy, Azzlack Professor
Schon mit 18 habe ich mein' Block versorgt
John Borno: Wo ist mein Taxi?
Wo ist mein Taxi?
Aber woher kommen die Drogen, die in den Taxis
verkauft werden und wie funktioniert das Geschäft
dahinter?
Wir begeben uns auf Spurensuche.
Über deutsche Drogentaxis…
...bis ins libanesische Hinterland.
Wenn du 1000 Quadratmeter Haschisch pflanzt, hast du kein Risiko.
Es lässt sich immer verkaufen.
Haschisch anzubauen ist also risikofrei für
den Bauern.
Eine Reise dorthin, wo Haschisch tonnenweise
hergestellt wird:
einer top Qualität und einer schnellen Lieferzeit.
Der Beginn der Recherche:
Wir finden in der Messenger-App Telegram verschiedene
Gruppenchats.
Hier werden ganz offen Drogen angeboten.
Gras oder Kokain per Taxi – ist das tatsächlich
so einfach ? Wir schreiben den Dealer an,
fragen, ob er auch uns beliefern kann.
Die Antwort:
20 Minuten später.
Ein Auto fährt vor.
Darin zwei junge Männer
Haben wir miteinander geschrieben?
Ja.
Wollt ihr einfach einsteigen?
Sofort zeigt er uns ein halbes Gramm Koks,
Preis: 50 Euro.
Lange sei er noch nicht dabei.
Wenn wir für ihn werben, sagt er, bekämen
wir Rabatt.
An der nächsten Ecke lässt er uns wieder
raus.
Das Koks lassen wir drin.
Überall in Deutschland sind Koks und Gras
leicht zu bekommen - mit dem Drogentaxi, oder
beim Dealer an der Ecke.
Wie hier in Berlin.
Ermittler bestätigen: Das Geschäft werde
beherrscht von kriminellen Mitgliedern einzelner
Großfamilien aus dem Libanon und der Türkei.
Ein erheblicher Anteil der Rauschgift-Kriminalität
wird aus diesen Kreisen begangen.
Wenngleich sich auch arabische Großfamilien
oder Kriminelle in dem Fall oder ClanMitglieder,
die kriminell sind, sich nicht auf Rauschgift
beschränken.
Aber es macht einen ganz großen Teil aus.
Oberstaatsanwalt Ralph Knispel betont: Nur
eine Minderheit agiere kriminell.
Wir treffen uns mit einem älteren Herren,
einen Libanesen.
Er kennt die kriminellen Strukturen in Berlin
gut
und will nicht erkannt werden.
Deshalb stellen wir das Interview nach.
Die Strafen in Deutschland sind lasch, die
lachen.
Ich habe einen Freund, der hat 110 Kilo Koks
hierher gebracht und verkauft.
Er hat 12 Jahre gekriegt.
Dann hat er mit dem Staatsanwalt gesprochen,
und andere verpfiffen.
Er kam nach 2 Jahren frei, hatte genug Geld.
Er hat viele Häuser gekauft - in der Türkei
und im Libanon.
Davon lebt er bis heute.
Er erinnert sich:
So wie er fliehen in den 70er Jahren Tausende
vor dem Bürgerkrieg im Libanon nach West-Berlin.
Sie werden geduldet, dürfen aber nicht arbeiten,
Sprachkurse gibt es nicht, Integration findet
nicht statt.
Kaum Geld, viel Langeweile.
Das habe Kriminalität gefördert: Bilder
einer Razzia von 1980.
Ein Lokal in der Potsdamer Straße, Treffpunkt
libanesischer Heroinhändler.
… Hände hoch.
"Die Leute waren neugierig auf Geld - dann
fingen die an mit Rauschgift.
Erst schmuggelten sie das Haschisch in Oliven
und Heroin in Schuhsohlen.
Das Geschäft wurde größer, ging vom Vater
zum Sohn.
Von 1978 bis zum heutigen Tag."
Bis heute sollen Drogen aus dem Libanon nach
Deutschland kommen.
Wir reisen dorthin, wollen wollen wissen,
welche Rolle das Land im internationalen Drogenhandel
spielt.
Beirut.
Der Libanon lebt vor allem vom Geld der 14
Millionen Libanesen, die im Ausland wohnen.
Der Staat ist schwach, viele Politiker gelten
als korrupt.
Nach tagelangen Vorgesprächen treffen wir
uns nachts mit einem Dealer in den Straßen
Beiruts.
Woher kommen all die Drogen?
"Das Kokain kommt aus Südamerika, Haschisch
aber produzieren wir hier, in den Bergen."
Und die Regierung lässt das zu?
"Natürlich wissen die davon, sie machen das
ja erst möglich.
Die sind korrupt."
Das heißt mit dem nötigen Schmiergeld kriegt
man alle Drogen raus und rein ins Land?
"Ja, alle Drogen!
Aber es kostet."
Er nimmt uns mit in seine Wohnung.
Dort zeigt er uns frische Ware– kiloweise
Haschisch, es kommt aus der Gegend.
Wir wollen dorthin, wo das Haschisch produziert
wird.
Von Beirut aus reisen wir ins libanesische
Hinterland.
Je weiter wir in die Berge kommen, umso dichter
hängen Flaggen der Hesbollah.
Im Libanon eine Regierungspartei, die in Deutschland
als Terrororganisation gilt und verboten ist.
Nach zweieinhalb Stunden Fahrt erreichen wir
Yammoune.
Ein 6000 Einwohner-Dorf mitten zwischen Ackerflächen.
Im Dorf treffen wir Tallal Shreif.
Das Dorf wird beherrscht von einer Familie.
Dessen Oberhaupt ist auch Vorsitzender der
Gemeinde.
"Das Problem ist bei 1000 Quadratmetern Kartoffeln
hast du viele Risiken, viel Wasser, viel Zeit.
Haschisch anzubauen ist risikofrei für
den Bauern."
Er erzählt: Lieber als das Haschisch wären
ihm Touristen.
"Ich wäre gerne ein touristischer Ort, das
wäre mein Traum.
Statt dem Haschisch, Hotels, Cafes, Restaurants
eröffnen.
Ich würde gerne die Mentalität hier ändern."
Doch die Realität sieht anders aus.
Alllein in diesem Lagerraum: Schätzungsweise 150
kg Haschisch. Preis in Deutschland
circa 1,5 Millionen Euro.
Mit Sieben verschiedener Maschenweiten wird
Harz von den restlichen Pflanzenteilen getrennt.
Das gewonnene Harzpulver wird zu Haschisch
gepresst – bekannt als Roter Libanese.
Wenige Häuser weiter, das nächste Lager. Wahrscheinlich eine halbe Tonne Haschisch.
Ein syrischer Hilfsarbeiter beim Sieben – diesmal
mit Maschine.
20 Tonnen exportiere Yammune jährlich, erzählen
die Einwohner.
Junge Männer aus dem Dorf nehmen uns mit
aufs Feld.
Vor der Kamera präsentieren sie ihre Kalaschnikows
und demonstrieren, was passiert, wenn die
Polizei kommt.
"Das passiert mit jedem, der
unser Land betritt."
"Und was ist mit der Hesbollah - überall
hier hängen Flaggen?"
"Die Gegend hier gehört zur Hesbollah.
Aber sie können das nicht verbieten, weil
dann wären sie in einem Kampf mit ihren eigenen
Leuten.
Hier ist es so, der eine Bruder arbeitet für
die Partei, der andere mit Haschisch.
Denkst Du die beiden Brüder würden darüber
streiten?
Das würde sie doch voneinander trennen."
Ein rechtsfreier Raum, in dem Großfamilien
ihren Geschäften nachgehen, geduldet von
der Hesbollah.
Das geht schon seit Jahrzehnten so, glaubt
man den Schilderungen von Großvater Haj.
Ich kenne Europa, ich war sogar schon mal
in Frankfurt und München.
Früher brachte ich so 100, 200 Kilo.
Mit dem Auto über die Türkei oder per Schiff
Libanon, Italien von da weiter nach Holland,
Frankreich und Deutschland.
Wir fahren weiter.
Sind verabredet mit einem Mann, der zum Umfeld
einer kriminellen arabischen Großfamilie
in Berlin gehört.
Zur Zeit lebt er im Südlibanon.
Er will nicht erkannt werden.
Prahlerei gehört zum Geschäft:
"Araber haben es einfach im Blut, dieses Adrenalin, um etwas Krasses zu machen.
Das ist der Grund, warum in Deutschland die
Ausländer und die Araber und die Libanesen
den Drogenmarkt in der Hand haben."
Er kann erklären, wie die Geschäfte ablaufen.
In Deutschland werde das Haschisch mit großen
Gewinn verkauft, das Geld werde gewaschen
und fließe in Form von Waren zurück in den
Libanon:
Die Leute kaufen zum Beispiel irgendwelche
Ware mit, schicken die mit Containern hierher.
Hier in Libanon wird ja nichts hergestellt.
Alles was aus Deutschland kommt wird hier
verwendet.
Auch Taschen voller Geld kämen direkt aus
Deutschland.
Fest steht: bis zu 10.000 Euro pro Person
sind nicht anmeldepflichtig.
Und Kontrollen am Flughafen finden nur stichprobenartig
statt.
"Von Tegel fliegt jeden zweiten Tag ein Flieger nach Beirut, und immer wenn jemand herkommt
sagt er, Kannst du für mich 10.000 mitnehmen?
Zum Beispiel eine Familie: 4 Leute, sind 40.000,
30.000.
Alles noch im grünen Bereich.
Da hat er hier auf einmal wieder 200.000.
So funktioniert das.
Zurück in Deutschland.
In Berlin kennen die Ermittler die Methoden.
Der Kampf dagegen sei schwierig:
Es ist sicherlich bekannt auch den Strafverfolgern,
dass auf derartigen Wegen sicherlich Gelder
geschmuggelt werden können.
Aber es gibt viel einfachere Wege, Beträge
werden überwiesen von Personen, die wir nicht
kennen.
Und gerade wenn sie beispielsweise in kleineren
Chargen überweisen, dann greifen auch diese
Verdachts Anzeigen nicht.
Und so wird es ganz sicher schwierig sein
diese Gelder aufzudecken.
Vergangenes Jahr hat die Politik die Strategie
der Tausend Nadelstiche ausgerufen.
Seitdem regelmäßige Razzien.
Tatverdächtige sollen nicht zur Ruhe kommen.
Ob so tatsächlich kriminelle Strukturen aufgebrochen
werden?
Das ist ein Marathonlauf.
Wir sind gerade gestartet, und die andere
Seite hat einen ganz immensen Vorteil.
Das heißt der Spurt, den wir im Moment einlegen,
der wird zu kurzzeitigen Erfolgen führen.
Aber auf der ganzen Strecke müssen wir sehen,
dass wir tatsächlich diese Verfolgungsdichte
und Intensität aufrechterhalten.
Denn ansonsten wird dieses Projekt kläglich
scheitern.
All die Maßnahmen werden nicht greifen, solange
die Nachfrage nach Haschisch und Kokain ungebrochen
ist.
In Berlin bietet der Cowboy weiter Drogen
an:
Weltweit haben Länder Drogen teilweise legalisiert.
Ist das ein sinnvoller Weg, um Drogenkriminalität
zu bekämpfen?
Schreibt eure Meinung in die Kommentare!